en el vídeo anterior resolvimos este
problema de la manera difícil quizás lo
vieron quizás no lo vieron
a lo mejor dijeron sabes que no me
interesa ver la forma difícil quiero que
me enseñes la forma fácil bueno vamos a
hablar de esto ahora y resulta que hay
un truco y el truco es que después de
que resolvemos este problema de la
manera difícil con la masa de 5
kilogramos y la masa de 3 kilogramos
cuando encontramos la aceleración nos
queda esto que la aceleración de la masa
de 5 kilogramos es de 29.4 newtons
dividida entre 5 kilogramos y cuando
realizamos los suficientes problemas nos
damos cuenta de que a veces 29.4 newtons
bueno vemos que esto es la fuerza de
gravedad que está jalando a esta masa de
3 kilogramos en otras palabras la única
fuerza que está impulsando todo este
sistema la única fuerza externa que está
poniendo en movimiento a estas masas es
equivalente a 8 kilogramos aquí
y dicen haber un momento 8 kilogramos es
igual a 5 kilogramos más 3 kilogramos es
esto coincidencia o esto nos está
indicando algo más fundamental no es
coincidencia de hecho siempre obtenemos
esto lo que obtenemos al final de
resolver esto de la manera difícil es
que tenemos todas las fuerzas externas
sumadas aquí tenemos las fuerzas que
hacen que esto se mueva como la fuerza
de gravedad que resulta ser positiva y
las fuerzas que tratan de resistirse al
movimiento si hubiera fricción ésta
sería una fuerza externa que trataría de
resistirse al movimiento estaría aquí y
pondríamos la masa total abajo y esto
tiene sentido ya que la aceleración de
todo este sistema si lo visualizamos
como un solo objeto imaginamos que todo
esto es un solo objeto
y nos preguntamos cuál es la aceleración
total en todo este sistema pues solo va
a depender de las fuerzas externas en
este caso la única fuerza externa que
hace que esto se mueva es esta fuerza de
gravedad de aquí
y ustedes me pueden decir a ver espera
qué pasa con estas tensiones acaso esta
atención no está jalando mi masa de 5
kilogramos y haciendo que esto se mueva
pues sí lo es pero resulta que ahora es
una fuerza interna si tratamos a todo
este sistema como un solo objeto pues
tenemos aquí esta tensión que hace que
esto se mueva pero también tenemos esta
otra tensión que está siendo resistencia
al movimiento y esto es lo que hacen las
fuerzas internas son iguales y opuestas
en alguna parte del objeto por lo que no
podemos hacer un movimiento con una
fuerza interna estás en esencia termina
en cancelándose mutuamente y la única
fuerza que nos queda en este caso es la
fuerza de gravedad y también nos queda
la masa total aquí abajo y este es el
truco para encontrar la aceleración en
un sistema que puede parecernos
complicado y que tengamos que resolver
con varias ecuaciones y varias
incógnitas
una vez que nos damos cuenta de esto
resolverlo se vuelve mucho más fácil y
esto muchas veces lo denominamos cómo
resolver el sistema como un solo objeto
y vamos a ver cómo se aplica vamos a
deshacernos de todo esto qué vamos a
hacer cuando nos encontramos un sistema
que tiene varios objetos que requieren
moverse con exactamente la misma
magnitud de aceleración porque a lo
mejor están atados con una cuerda o
quizás están empujando mutuamente
a lo mejor hay muchas cajas formadas y
estas cajas están siendo empujadas con
la misma aceleración porque no pueden
empujarse de manera que se atraviesen
mutuamente si tenemos una condición en
la que varios objetos tienen que moverse
con la misma magnitud de aceleración
entonces podremos encontrar la
aceleración de este sistema como si
fuera un solo objeto aplicamos la
segunda ley de newton pero en lugar de
estar buscando objetos individuales para
encontrar cierta dirección
vamos a considerar todas las fuerzas
externas de nuestro sistema considerando
las como si estuvieran actuando sobre un
solo objeto todo esto dividido entre la
masa total del sistema cuando ponemos
estas fuerzas externas y externos
significa que no son internas al sistema
si considero esta masa de 5 kilogramos y
la masa de 3 kilogramos como una sola
masa la atención quedaría adentro sería
una fuerza interna ya que se aplicaría
internamente entre los objetos que se
encuentran dentro del sistema pero la
fuerza de gravedad sobre la masa de los
tres kilogramos es una fuerza externa
porque se trata de la tierra que está
jalando esta masa y en la tierra no es
parte de nuestro sistema de manera
similar
nuestra fuerza normal es una fuerza
externa
en este caso se cancela con la fuerza de
gravedad por lo que aunque éstas también
son fuerzas externas no van a aparecer
en nuestra fórmula es decir las pueden
poner pero se van a cancelar mutuamente
y solo buscamos fuerzas que tengan la
dirección del movimiento y como esto
causa este movimiento vamos a
considerarla como una fuerza positiva
las fuerzas que van en dirección del
movimiento como la fuerza de gravedad
aquí las vamos a considerar positivas y
las fuerzas que vamos a poner aquí que
sean positivas son las que hacen que se
mueva el sistema y esto podría parecer
extraño y me pueden decir cómo puedo
darme cuenta de cuando una fuerza hace
que se mueva el sistema pues se pueden
preguntar esta fuerza tiene la misma
dirección que el movimiento del sistema
si decimos bueno este sistema se va a
acelerar y hay fuerzas que hacen que se
mueva estas serán mis fuerzas positivas
y las fuerzas negativas son
las fuerzas que hacen resistencia al
movimiento del sistema aquellas fuerzas
que lo quieren detener que se resisten
al movimiento del sistema en este caso
el ejemplo de acá no tengo ninguna de
estas fuerzas de resistencia en este
caso no tenemos ninguna aunque podríamos
tenerla si yo aquí tuviera la fuerza de
fricción entonces tendría una fuerza
externa que se resiste al movimiento del
sistema y pondría esta fuerza externa
como negativa y aunque esto les pueda
sonar extraño tiene sentido si
reflexionan sobre ello la aceleración de
nuestro sistema visto como un solo
objeto solamente va a depender de
aquellas fuerzas que tratan de mover al
sistema y en las fuerzas que tratan de
resistirse al movimiento de este sistema
si ponemos estos como positivos y
negativos respectivamente y lo dividimos
entre la masa total que es la medida de
la inercia de nuestro sistema tendremos
la aceleración de este sistema tiene
sentido y además funciona esto siempre
nos va a funcionar
y nos ahorra muchísimo tiempo por
ejemplo si queremos resolver este
problema y nos dijeran resuelve lo como
quieras yo usaría este método diría que
la aceleración del sistema que se
compone de esta masa de 5 kilogramos y
de esta masa de tres kilogramos va a ser
igual y ahora me pregunto cuáles son las
fuerzas que hacen que el sistema se
mueva que fuese es la que está
impulsando este sistema y resulta que es
la fuerza de gravedad en esta masa de
tres kilogramos si quitamos esta fuerza
de aquí nada va a pasar nada se va a
mover esta es la fuerza que hace que se
mueva todo el sistema la pongo aquí con
signo positivo como mis tres kilogramos
por 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado y
aquí se pueden preguntar bueno esta
gravedad de aquí hace que se mueva el
sistema esta gravedad acá también hace
lo mismo no en este caso no esta
gravedad es perpendicular al movimiento
por lo que esta gravedad no está
haciendo que se mueva el sistema
lo hace que esta masa se quede encima de
esta mesa y además esta fuerza está
cancelada por la fuerza normal así que
estás aunque son fuerzas externas se
cancelan mutuamente y esta es la única
fuerza que me está afectando al sistema
que está haciendo que se mueva lo pongo
esto aquí y lo divido entre mi masa
total que es lo que me dice que tanto se
está resistiendo mi sistema al
movimiento cual es la inercia o la
resistencia en el cambio de la velocidad
y con esto obtengo exactamente lo mismo
que obtuve en la vez pasada tengo de
nuevo mis 3 puntos 68 metros por segundo
al cuadrado y esto lo obtuve con una
sola ecuación este truco es genial y
funciona cada vez funciona en todos los
problemas en donde tenemos dos o más
masas que se están moviendo con la misma
magnitud de aceleración así que eso es
excelente y nos ahorra mucho tiempo y
para enseñarles lo útil que es digamos
que aquí si hay fricción digamos que
tenemos un coeficiente de fricción de
0.3 ahora tengo una fuerza de fricción
que es una fuerza externa esta fuerza de
fricción va para acá y que se aplica a
esta masa de 5 kilogramos por lo que
tengo que restar la aquí y ahora quito
esto ya no va a ser este valor
tengo mi fuerza de fricción que voy a
restar por lo que tengo menos mi fuerza
de fricción y para calcular mi fuerza de
fricción vamos a escribir esto aquí
antes de 29.4 newtons menos
la fuerza de fricción tiene esta fórmula
la fuerza de fricción siempre es mucho o
el coeficiente de fricción por la fuerza
normal no la fuerza normal en todo el
sistema no voy a incluir esta masa de
tres kilogramos es solamente la fuerza
normal en esta masa de 5 kilogramos que
es la que está contribuyendo con esta
fuerza de fricción aquí y aunque veo en
el sistema como un todo aún tenemos que
encontrar fuerzas en estos objetos
individuales y de forma correcta por lo
que aquí no va a toda la masa la fuerza
normal en la masa de 5 kilogramos va a
ser de 5 kilogramos por 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado lo divido entre mi
masa total todo esto de aquí ya que toda
la masa es la que está resistiendo el
movimiento debido a la inercia y si
despejó a mi aceleración en el sistema
tendré 1.84 metros por segundo al
cuadrado por lo que esto es menor que
nuestra aceleración de 3.68
tiene sentido ya que hay una fuerza de
resistencia una fuerza externa de
resistencia que trata de evitar que se
mueva el sistema pero aquí tenemos que
tener cuidado lo que yo estoy
encontrando aquí es solamente la
magnitud de la aceleración esto es solo
la magnitud si yo estoy definiendo que
todo lo que hace que se mueva el sistema
va a tener signo positivo y todas las
fuerzas que se resisten al movimiento
serán negativas aquí solamente tendré la
magnitud de la aceleración en las
diferentes masas tendrán esa magnitud de
aceleración pero podrían tener
aceleraciones positivas o negativas en
otras palabras esta masa de 5 kilogramos
se está acelerando a la derecha y tiene
una aceleración positiva es decir la
aceleración en esta masa de 5 kilogramos
va a ser de 1.84 metros por segundo al
cuadrado positivo y la aceleración en la
masa de los tres kilogramos ya que se
está acelerando hacia abajo será de
menos 1.84 metros por segundo al
cuadrado